they were knocking this place dead for
years
cheaters justice oh my gosh
we do not use chainsaws in the back room
uh anymore
hey gq i'm dustin beaucheers director of
casino operations at red rock casino and
this
is the breakdown
[Music]
first up casino royale with this chip
exchange we enter the final
phase of the game which means no more
buy-ins the big blind is now one million
dollars
basically what they're saying is that
you can't buy any more cash whatever's
on that game right now in chips is it
you got to keep playing the game until
somebody wins
four players so the game they're playing
right now is no limit texas hold'em
it is the elite of the elite they say
that most players
can't play it because there's too much
stress this game basically you can bet
all your money in one hand
and a lot of other poker games you can't
do that and so you really got to have
some skill
i think a high stakes game is different
to everybody but in our world when we're
talking about millions of dollars then
that's pretty much a high stakes game
these kind of games do happen they're
going to be either in back rooms of a
casino
from a table games perspective not so
much poker you would actually have
salons or private rooms
the average person is not going to
usually just kind of stumble upon those
most guests feel intimidated to go into
a salon or into a room but
here in nevada you're allowed to go in
the room now there are some things
called private salons
the normal guests can't just walk into
that room but uh that would be the only
exclusion to that
pond check check the term check means
basically you're just saying i don't
want to bet any money now ultimately if
another player does decide to bet more
money
then you either have to make the choice
to bet the same or more or
fold your hand folding the hand means
basically i'm throwing in i give up
you're going to end up beating me
check check or check
four players let's pause it right here
so i think they're doing this for
cinematic reasons but the dealer's
talking way too much
especially on a high-end game like this
these are all professional poker players
you're not going to have a dealer
sitting there going
he checks he checks he checks no the
player says check so this is way out of
character and on those really high-end
games
the dealer's not going to say a word
unless they have to because they know
what kind of money is being played on
the table
that is 6 million
those blue square looking rectangular
things that you see on the table that
they have those are actually called
plaques
they're usually used in really high-end
salons where they'll use them as
a 100 or even a million dollars
representation but it's basically like a
chip it's very very common
in europe that they use those but we
rarely see those and i don't know if
i've ever seen them in a poker room here
in the united states other than really
obscure time
race race
12 million heads up with this kind of
high high end
this is the kind of game you would
expect is a no limit texas hold'em it's
definitely one of the more difficult
poker games
the goal is to get the strongest hand or
the best hand out of all the other
players that are actually playing in
that round
you can end up winning with the worst
hand because nobody else has a hand
better than you
or in this situation you're going to win
with the most absurd set of hands you've
ever seen
james bond is trying to determine if
he's bluffing meaning you're acting
that you have a really strong hand that
the other player can't beat like this
long delay here where they're staring
each other down
the game is like set there's nothing
else anybody can do there's no more
action that anybody can do
basically everybody on the table is all
in at this point so the dealer would
start
having the players show their hand
gentlemen show down please
let's pause it right here this isn't
accurate what would happen is the two
biggest players right here
james bond and the bad guy would show
their cards because they have the most
money in the pot in this situation
you would also have what we call side
pots because
the first couple players on the game
they're going for really small amounts
so if that guy who only bet the five
million dollars
if he had the best hand out of all the
players he would only win five million
from each of the players because all he
put in
was five million he's not going to win
the total 115 million because
he didn't bet the equivalent to the
other players and so
how they're showing the scene is not the
proper format of a normal poker game
flash ace king queen
this is also something you would not do
would happen is the players would
flip over their hands show what they
would have all those players are
professional poker players they would
instantly see the other players hands
and know who's the winner
in this scene the dealer's like taking
each guest's hand and adding it
to the board which can also cause
problems because ultimately a guest
could say that wasn't my hand
so this is not a normal procedure
[Music]
i hire full house this is full of sixes
for all these players to have these
super super strong hands on this massive
pot
is so unrealistic and i've never seen
anything like this happen
the chance of this happening is one in
millions for this kind of event to occur
then ultimately james bond wins with a
straight flush i know they did it to be
dramatic and make it seem like it's
really big action but it's kind of just
hilarious to me
is your pawn wins
thank you very much everybody has
different ideas of how to tip a deal or
when to tip a dealer but ultimately i
think most dealers would say is
when a guest is winning that hey share
some of the wealth share some of the
winnings with me
i saw a player one time who won 30 000
like the dealer so much
just handed it right into the dealer
everybody you know tips in a different
way
but that's the dealer's livelihood they
make basically minimum wage
so make sure you tip your dealers very
important i've seen
not on poker games but on blackjack
games and on roulette games
i've seen people win millions of dollars
i think the average player out there
they don't know that there's players out
there that exist like that but there are
some definitely huge players that come
in and bet millions of dollars
i've seen players play half a million
dollars a spin on roulette
so people are betting my house every
spin on the wheel
next up casino you can spot these ass
by watching the way they bet like this
guy
he's been lavender chips at 500 each
with only one little problem
he's always guessed right if you pause
it right here you actually see that he
doubles down on an eight and you would
never double down on an eight versus a
ten which is the dealer's up card
that's a telltale sign for us that when
we see that we go hold on okay this guy
made a bad decision
and it ended up paying off for him let's
take a closer look at this guy
there's this belief that we would be
standing right on the table staring down
the guests and back in the day you had
to do that a little bit more because the
technology wasn't there
but nowadays with the surveillance
technology i can be sitting in my office
staring at a screen and making those
determinations right there the camera
technology is amazing so we can pick up
on
all the details of the game but at the
end of the day it's still nice to be on
the floor you get the vibe of what's
going on they actually do a really good
job in this movie of
portraying our role in our job it shows
that
they definitely had somebody with some
casino background helping them on
setting this scene up
i saw that the dealer was weak but he
wasn't in on it
he just wasn't protecting his hand we do
similar things
we'll try to play it off like hey i'm
tying my shoe or i'm looking at
something else but i'm actually paying
attention to that suspect
i will do things to make sure they're
not paying attention to me
if i see a guest looking at me and what
i'm doing i become suspicious because at
the end of the day
people come to the casino to gamble the
dealer was weak but he wasn't in on it
he just wasn't protecting his hand he
was lifting his whole card way too high
this technique right here is a very old
school we now have what we call the
games are peakers
it's a little mirror that you actually
slide the card into
so you never have to bend up the card
anymore like this this is a traditional
way
actually how this dealer is doing it
he's doing a very poor job anybody
standing behind the game or slightly off
to the side
is going to be able to see that whole
card and having that whole card changes
the whole dynamics of the game and gives
that player
that huge edge the proper way of doing
that would be basically taking the hands
and bending this cupping it so that you
couldn't see
from any angle here's this guy reading
the dealer's whole card
the device he's using is sending
electrical signal to another device
that's tapping his leg telling him what
the
whole card is most likely what he's
doing is he's tapping it six times it
says
hey that whole card is a six that player
is going to take advantage of that eight
because he knows the dealer has a 16
he's gonna double down on that eight
normally a bad decision but when you
know what the dealer has it's a great
decision
as soon as they started using that
device they made it a crime now
there's a difference between an
advantage player and an actual cheat or
criminal in my mind
if the big player was just being able to
see the whole card because the dealer
was weak but they weren't using a device
or anything else that would be more just
a weak deal that's exposing the card and
the guest is taking advantage of that
currently there's not a law against that
the technology that we're seeing in this
is so old the new technology that we see
today
is so advanced from cell phones to
miniature cameras
we hear about all these new scams and
new ways of people cheating us one of
the ways that
is common is marking or dobbing cards
on the back side of the card or this
part here
you would end up either making
indentations with your nails or you
would use a substance
that you would put on the card itself
that isn't visible
easily or it can't be seen with the
normal naked eye nowadays
they have actually contacts that people
will put in their eye that see a
specific
color or ink there's also what we call
player dealer collusion
this is where a dealer and a player work
together to cheat the game
so what they're going to do is actually
peak the car so they're going to just
expose this very corner right here
so that the guests can see is this a
card i want or i don't want there's
hundreds of ways people
cheat but at the end of the day the one
that scares me the most and scares the
other operators
is the scam we don't know about that new
scam that somebody's come up with
that we're waiting to discover and it's
our job to try
to uh prevent it at all times once i
discover somebody's cheating
it's very important that we actually
have all the evidence that we need
before we go and confront that suspect
back in those days they didn't have to
worry about that they just take the
guests off the game
pull them in a back room and those
guests would talk real quick
nowadays you have to take very soft
approach to everything
i like to always tell people when they
hear about somebody cheating or somebody
getting arrested at a casino that would
be better for you to reach
into the actual rack where we keep our
chips take a hundred dollars and run out
the door
than it would be for you to cheat with
one dollar cheating is so much more
frowned upon
and is ultimately in the courts is
usually much harsher
it is something you do not want to do
basically using this as a distraction so
that the two suspects
won't go and run off or feel the heat
when the security starts to surround the
table
we don't really do that these days what
we do is we usually just kind of avoid
the table that we're looking at or the
suspects
and then ultimately when we're ready to
go in then it's a fast
thing so that suspect didn't even know
that we were coming in after them
[Music]
using a cattle prod to take the suspect
into custody
is not done nowadays back in the day
there was all kinds of techniques used
uh i didn't work during that era but
i've heard a lot of stories about things
that were done
but currently we cannot use a catapro to
take a suspect into custody
for cheating or for any other reason
they were knocking this place dead for
years
we do not use chainsaws in the back room
uh anymore
did this occur in the past i've heard
stories of it people that accidentally
fell down stairs and
hammers were taken to the hands and
other things but currently obviously in
the environment we
live in today we handle everybody in a
professional manner but this is
once again there's a great depiction of
how things used to be here in town
in fact the movie casino is based off of
real life characters when i came up in
the business a lot of the guys that
taught me that had been in the business
30 plus years worked alongside those
guys and knew those guys personally
now everything's on the up and up and
we're highly regulated with the gaming
control board and were run by
corporations
but back in the day the mob did run
things here in town
next up the hangover hey guys did you
find it
nope but check this out
all right let's pause it right here so
this is comical
the character here is attempting to
count cards you can see him talking what
the count is
with his lips this is like the most
amateur level of card counting you could
be at
where you would be like plus one minus
one plus two with your lips
this is something you just do in your
head you don't actually voice it out
card counting is the technique
that has been around for a while but
basically what it is
is you're keeping track of the small
cards in your mind
when you have a two through six that's
considered a plus
one and when you have a ten or an ace
that's minus one
as the cards are played you're keeping
track of that count
and when the count gets real positive
real high then you would increase your
wagers because it's more favorable to
you the player they're going to be more
tens and aces coming out
and then as the count goes negative or
below zero
those cards are going to be a lot of
small cards and it's going to be less of
an advantage for you to play
card counting is completely legal in the
state of nevada
you can card count but i have the right
as an operator to refuse service to
anybody
so that's ultimately what we do is we
just ask the guest that
we no longer want them to play blackjack
yes you can learn the basics of card
counting from a book
but ultimately to become a professional
and somebody who does it for a career
it takes months upon months of training
it is not something you can just read a
book
on your way into vegas and decide that
you're going to be a card counter those
books that people have written have
actually made us millions of dollars
because players think they're card
counters
after reading this book they come in and
they lose all their money and ultimately
they are not a card counter
hey come on he can't lose he can't lose
i think the pit boss is watching we
don't take a clipboard and put it up
against our face when
we're talking to each other in the pit
like that even if we're talking about
a player that we're suspecting he's
doing something or card counting we
would just talk normal
we'd probably not even be looking in
your direction so that you wouldn't even
suspect that we're talking about you
but the noises in the casino really make
it hard for anybody else to hear
conversations that are a couple feet
away
we're not going to fall for that we see
people acting crazy and doing all kinds
of things to distract us
just because you escaped from the table
with the chips you still got to cash out
those chips we can still meet you at the
cage and tell you we don't want your
play anymore
or we can wait until you come back
another day and ultimately ask that you
don't play blackjack anymore
next up 21. let's go make a killing
all right
[Music]
this is an advantaged team basically and
they're all
drinking before they're gonna go play
blackjack advantage players are not
in this to go have fun get drunk and
have a good time gambling
they're in it to make money you would
not see an advantage team
drinking a bunch of drinks before they
go out to count cards
flak jackson games is several hundred
years old the ultimate goal is to get
closest to 21 without going over
and have a better hand than the dealer
the actual term 21
is basically a ace in a jack or
blackjack
guests always want to get blackjack
that's the best hand you can get
in that game and that's why it's named
blackjack hangover was kind of a parody
or a joke
the movie 21 is much more accurate in
describing how card counting works
and what it was to be in an advantaged
team
[Music]
hey you mind if i sit down you can see
she folds her hands behind the table
what she's been doing is she's been
counting cards on that table betting
very small
and then she's basically signaling in
the big players saying
hey the count's really good you come
over as the big player
you really can't do this play anymore
but what they were doing is camouflaging
or preventing management me and the
other supervisors
from catching you as an advantage player
or card counter in this scene you'll see
that
they're wearing disguises people will
think that it's for the movies no this
is really true
to this day we catch advantage players
coming in with all kinds of disguises
longer hair beards they use these
disguises
to hope that we won't notice it's them
and uh get in and play as much as they
can
before they get caught in this situation
she's counting down the game
and he comes in at the right time when
she calls him in and
bets big and wins big
so the signaling they're using would be
something that i may not pick up on the
first time but after a couple of times
watching this player
it would be something we would
definitely notice it's just like
anything else repetition if you see it
over and over again
eventually you'll see it as something
that you want to take a look at
does he know this female do they walk
out of the casino at the same time
do we notice them anywhere else in the
casino that's another way we catch
people is
they may act like they don't know each
other on the table but then they walk
out in the parking garage and get in the
same car
advantage players try to be sneaky and
it's kind of a counter surveillance
situation
how do we catch card counters i am a
card counter basically we learn to count
cards
just as good as they do we count the
cards as they're counting them
and then determine if their bets
correlate with the count
and that's ultimately how we back them
off and i will also put this myth to bed
the belief is that you can't count down
a six deck shoe or an eight deck shoe
a shoe is basically a device that holds
the cards that we
deal the cards out of we can count down
100 deck shoe if you wanted to so
it doesn't matter the amount of decks in
a shoe an advantage player can count
down as many decks as you put out there
next up swingers start with a
300.
instantly the scene you can tell the two
guys are amateurs
and they're also playing with scared
money it's money that they probably
can't afford to gamble
they're counting the money over and over
again in the scene they don't know that
they don't need to count the money they
just put the money on the table the
dealer will count out the money and tell
them exactly how much money it is
they're trying to act like they're high
rollers but they don't even know the
procedures on the game or how to play
the game properly on the table
excuse me you have to lay it on the
table i don't want to bet at all
not allowed to hand me money sir you
have to lay it on the table
if you want me to change it we can't
take anything out of a guest hands
and this goes back to game protection or
possibility of cheating and so
we make sure that there's no
hand-to-hand touching
of anything because d-look player could
pass something off to each other
that could be used for cheating do you
uh have anything smaller
yes as a matter of fact i do but this
happens to be a 100
minimum bet table perhaps you'd be more
comfortable at one of our lower stakes
tables
the dealers being a jerk right off the
bat the dealers work on tips and so
given the player an attitude like that
is not going to work out well for it
works out good for the movie for a
little banter but at the end of the day
a dealer should always act nice to a
guest because you never know when
they're going to be a big tipper
cocktail the scotch on the rocks please
any scotch will do
as long as it's not a blend of course uh
single malt
glenolyvic plant fitting perhaps maybe
glenn gow any glenn
he's trying to act sophisticated and
trying to order some kind of expensive
scotch or something that's
high end we know what high rollers look
like and how they act
big players are confident they know what
they want
they also don't have to ask for things
they just expect things for themselves
double down what about an 11 you always
double down 11 i know but it's 200
he's giving him a good advice that's a
common known fact you always double down
on 11 for the most part
doubling down is basically you get the
ability to double the amount of money
that's out on the table for your hand
but you only get one more card
ultimately why do you double down at 11
because the most common card in the deck
is a 10 so the likelihood of you getting
a 10 would be
very common basic strategy after
millions of hands has determined that if
you have an 11 against
basically any other card for the dealer
that the right move is to double down
i'm telling you baby you always double
down on the left yeah well obviously not
always
always i'm just saying not in this
particular case
you always double that i lost okay how
could you say
i always give people the advice is just
stick with whatever you do every time
that way you're not beating yourself up
later if you made a different decision
so
if you always double on 11 then always
double on 11. the lady has 11 what would
you like to do
um
[Music]
15. i don't know what to do here okay
this is a typical low limit game where
you probably have a player who hasn't
played blackjack a lot doesn't know the
proper basic strategy
in this scene the dealer's showing a
five as the up card so anything
basically
past 11 you're going gonna stand on that
in this situation
she keeps hitting until she gets to 21
with all these small cards
normally that would piss off all the
other players on the table because
they would think that she's taking all
the cards they would ultimately make the
dealer bust
but in this situation it ends up working
out the belief that she's going to make
your cards bad and ultimately you're
going to lose money because she's
playing bad
it's a proven fact that just because
other players on the game are making bad
decisions
those cards don't necessarily have an
effect on the outcome of whether you win
or lose per se
next up rounders no limit texas hold'em
is the cadillac of poker this movie
is the ultimate poker movie it is the
movie that
every poker player has seen multiple
times they do a really good job of
describing the poker world
the key to the game is playing the man
not the cards
there's more than just the cards like on
blackjack it's just the cards you
playing against the dealer
it's the cards in poker you're reading
the other players at the game
to see do they really have a good set of
cards the other thing that's really
important in poker is knowing the
statistics
an example would be like if you have
these two cards
what are the chances of this occurring
what are the chances of me winning with
these two cards i quality
so real quick let's pause it right here
with a high-end game like this even
though it's in an underground casino or
underground poker room
most likely a player would not be
dealing his own cards
especially with that kind of money they
would have a dealer on the game that
would just be dealing the cards to the
players
you would also not want the actual
player dealing the cards because
that player may be able to cheat
underground casinos do exist
i'm not aware of any but they do exist
and every once in a while you hear
something in the news about getting
exposed in different uh jurisdictions
here in the state of nevada if you want
to open a casino there's a whole process
you have to go through i would say to
have your
own little poker game at your house
you're probably not going to get busted
for that but if you have an underground
casino like this in rounders
those will get busted eventually
i just got top two pair on the flop so
the flop is the first three cards
that are community cards that are dealt
onto the board that means he has two
pairs
and they're the best pairs you can have
based off of the three cards that come
out
against your average guy i'd set a bear
trap hardly bet at all but kgb is too
smart for that
so what i've got to do is over bet the
pot meaning he's betting more than
what's in the pot like i said there's a
strategy to how the players play on the
game
and each player you play differently too
so he's saying
how much he's gonna bet he can either
act like he has a really strong hand
where he would bet a lot
or he can bet less and in this situation
he's betting more than what the money is
on the table right then
my guess is teddy's on a flush draw
flush draw means that he's
on a draw that has the possibility of
making a flush
he has four of the cards to a flush and
he needs one more or he has three cards
and he needs two more so
he's looking for another card of the
same suit
there's my money card nine of hearts i
got a full house
money card means that that's the card
that's gonna make me win the hand
so let's pause it right here this is
what we would call as a tell
they make it really obvious in the movie
just so that an amateur could tell
in this scene and as the movie plays you
determine that his character
anytime he has a good hand and he feels
strong about it he ends up eating the
oreo
and when he has a weaker hand and he
doesn't think he can win he ends up
putting the oreo back
into the little tray it's one of those
ways that make you a better poker
players being able to see those tells
15 000
time
matt damon is acting like he has to
really think about if he wants to play
this hand or not he's already determined
he's playing the hand but he's acting to
throw off the other character poker is
just like being an actor
you got to act on the game sometimes you
got to play it up a little bit
yeah i'm going to go all in because i
don't think you got the space
you're right i don't have
spades i know before the cards are even
turned over
this scene is done so much better than
the scene from casino royale
they both have competing hands one's
stronger than the other um they're
realistic hands
i mean heads up it's a little harder set
up than
normal heads up is basically when it's
player versus player there's only two
players in the game and they're going
against each other the chances of these
two hands occurring it doesn't happen a
lot
but it's much more realistic than casino
royale's outcome
it makes you uh enjoy the movie and and
see how much of a bad beat that is and a
bad beat is basically where
you thought you had the win you had it
you were good to go and ultimately you
get beat and every poker player will
tell you about
that bad beat they won't tell you about
the time they want a bunch of money but
they'll tell you about the time they
lost a bunch of money on a bad beat
next up vegas vacation teddy this place
is great
they don't have any of these games at
the mirage pick a number
i'm great at that this crazy casino off
the beaten path offers all these
weird games pick a number you can't
offer that game in the casino
there's so many different ways that it
could be cheated and manipulated
obviously
what's comical is they've thrown the
game war in which everybody's played as
a kid
thinking that oh this game doesn't exist
this game actually does exist in some
casinos and was popular for a period of
time rock raper scissors on the other
hand you cannot play in a casino on all
these games except war it would be very
easy for us to cheat the players
and there's no way to really regulate
where it would be a fair
game we're regulated by a gaming control
board that makes sure that the games
that we offer on the floor
gives the guest a certain percentage of
a chance
four seven
betty what am i doing throughout the
movie you can see him chasing the money
chasing money means you're chasing your
losses it means that if you lose a
hundred dollars on a game
you get frustrated and you're like i
gotta win my hundred dollars back so you
go take another hundred dollars out of
the atm
you try to win your hundred dollars back
well then you lose that second hundred
dollars now you're trying to win back
two hundred dollars and so
you're using more money to try to win
back the money that you already lost
the rumor that uh i'll put this to rest
right now
we do not pump oxygen into the casinos
that's one i hear all the time casinos
used to be built
where there weren't a lot of windows and
people to actually see out the doors
did that help the guests stay longer
yeah it did guests didn't realize what
time it was and they may play for
another
hour or two because they didn't see that
it was sunlight outside
now with modern casinos you see that
less and less there's glass doors and
people can actually see the light coming
in also you know the rumor is
that we don't have any clocks no we
don't usually have clocks in the casino
or around the slot floor or around the
table games
there's always a clock in the sports
book because you have to make bets by
certain time
by the time the game actually starts but
nowadays everybody has cell phones
everybody has watches so
guests can find out what time it is
anytime anyways there's a definitely a
skill and a
practice of how we set up our casino
floors most of that is set up
for the guests so they can find games
easier we want to have our best games
forward so that guests can find them so
there is a lot of thought and work put
into
where we put slot machines where we put
tables on the floor to optimize
the guest experience if a player is
willing to go to a casino and a casino
like this actually existed
the player doesn't deserve to have the
money that's in their pocket they're
going to get taken every time on these
kind of games
it's comical it's a great part for a
movie but it's so
far from the world i live in and the
world i work in clark griswold on this
scene
should just quit gambling throughout the
movie it's a telltale sign of somebody
who has a gambling problem
so clark griswold should stay out of
casinos
next up ocean's 13.
[Applause]
you get reception in here that's
impossible not with this phone
surveillance rooms don't look like the
room in ocean's 13. the surveillance
room is highly secure there's only very
limited amount of employees that can go
in there because it has access to
basically
all the information about the casino on
the cameras so only
my position casino shift managers and
above usually have
the authorization to even go in those
rooms server one is going down
now everyone in this room
empty your pockets now what's going on
this would not happen there's nothing
that shuts down the room and locks down
the room
they can pick up a cell phone they can
pick up another phone and make the phone
call if there is something going on
they would make a call to us if they
were to lose surveillance coverage
we're actually required by gaming
control board to always have
surveillance coverage so if we were to
lose it
we would ultimately have to contact
gaming and most likely shut down the
games
snake guys
[Music]
it looks like he puts down 100 to 150
000 on snake eyes snake eyes is aces or
1-1 on the dice no casino that i know of
would take that big of a wager and right
away if you saw that
you would go there's something super
suspicious going on you would stop the
game you wouldn't let it go forward
[Music]
there's several ways you could cheat
with dice you can manipulate the dice
themselves
you could shave the edges do things like
that you could also use loaded dice
which you would get a hold of a set of
dice
and you would load them with a magnet
and you could alter how the dice
roll and end up landing they would have
a switch was ultimately a little lighter
in this scene
a lot of times what they used to use is
they would have to have a bag or a
wheelchair that would have a device
right underneath the crafts table or
right where the player's standing
they would use a switch of some sort to
turn that on and then ultimately change
how the dice would roll
what's more common than using the loaded
dice is what we call dice sliding
the team or three or four people
basically what they do is
they make a distraction so that
everybody on the table is looking at
them
so that this one player can take the
dice slide them down the table
where they don't tumble and they stay on
the number that he slid down that table
that's much more common than using
loaded dice but we have a lot of
procedures in place
to prevent that every new stick of dice
we mic them which means we check the
balance of them
and make sure that the dice are even on
all the edges it's the same with when we
go
and open a deck of cards we make sure
all the cards are there that there's no
markings on the cards
that there are cards we keep that stuff
real close and under
a lot of scrutiny because we know that
if somebody gets a hold of one of those
items at gaming
equipment they could do a lot of damage
to the casino with that the system's in
lockdown
all calls in and out of this room are
secure unfortunately it's the system
that secures them
again sir it's in lockdown it wouldn't
happen in real life where one person
gets locked in a room and it prevents
them from
stopping all these people from cheating
the games how often do people try to rob
casinos
nothing like ocean's 13 what they end up
trying to do the most common one is
which we call a snatch and grab
a person will come up to a blackjack
table or craps game
jump over the top of the table grab the
chips from the rack
and then attempt to run out the door
with the chips this happens and
sometimes there's a group of people that
do it for a period of time and the
several casinos get hit
and then eventually the police or the
gaming agents catch them and put them in
jail these big
ones where they're going to knock over
the whole casino and do this it's just
too hard and too unrealistic
to actually happen it'd be more
realistic for you to rob the brinks
armored truck that's picking up all the
cash than it is for you to rob the
casino if you're gonna go rob something
go rob somewhere else don't rob
a casino thanks everybody for hanging
out and watching those clips with me
hope to see in the casino soon
[Music]